salut salut alors ce week-end c'est
super mais vous êtes avait chez la mère
cinéma
et toi alors ce week end
alors j'ai pris un bain d'eau des
montagnes ou scandinaves
pendant qu'à madrilène fout de moi
disait de la poésie salah et oui
non je devais faire réparer mon frigo et
réparateurs et papiers bon ma pauvre je
t'appelle d'accord ok
la glace il ya elle bouge comme une
femme je suis walter mitty chiril mais
geof
où étiez-vous jeux sont les limites de
l'espace humain j'adorerais faire
l'ascension de vaud relief je pourrais
vous envoyer des messages par la voix de
montfaucon boîte faux comporte ainsi
vous voyez qu'un trombone bien envoyé le
ferait bouger un peu excellente question
et s'est depuis lancé une cartouche
d'imprimante une fois et il a bougé je
les marque et fascinante anecdotes ride
control to médiator nous recevez-vous
médiator
à la cérémonie